solche kurzinfos wieder los geht es
schon nicht verwirklichen job zu machen
über den tag hier wieder zu suchen hat
es auch schon von morgens angefangen
allerdings ist dann heraus was
vielleicht an es entstand der block
kommt dann am sonntag also ich glaube
dass morgen noch ein bisschen ich will
nicht zu viel verraten jetzt besser
nicht gelesen hat mein bruder ist super
gemacht puste weg nicht und ich wünsche
jetzt viel spaß ich brauche das einfach
mal so ganz vorne auf
[Musik]
soweit wir haben jetzt kurz nach mittag
wird etwas dran
wir sind also wenn man hier untergeht
ist und strand es ist ganz sogar auf
jeden fall an diesem stand dahinter sind
nicht so viele leute
und ja das war mal ein bisschen die ruhe
genießen genommen war mein bruder von
auch mit weil spinne schon mit meinen
eltern und meinem bruder und meine
eltern und anderen anderen strand und
wir schauen was so geht das ding ist ich
war auf diese insel auf diese index von
irgendwie seit 18 jahren oder so also
ich bin wirklich jetzt zum achten mal
hier und man kennt sich ziemlich gut aus
mittlerweile glaube wir dürfen wir gar
nicht zusammen gehen
der durfte man hier noch lange von der
tristen das hier ist ein ganz normaler
weg moment ihre ihr könnt ja meine
kommentare schreiben bekennt auf jeden
fall ich werde gar nicht lang lagern
früher haben wir immer hier unten
geboren
also ich bin halt noch mit meinem bruder
einer woche nachgeflogen meine eltern
schon länger hier
sehr entspannt was besser pepsi cola
das honorieren die wohnzimmer noch genug
gleich mit dem schlüssel sollte ist das
ist ja das ist der stand also das ist
wirklich der schlimmste stand auf der
ganzen insel
die insel wirklich traumhaft schön aber
wir halten uns auf jeden fall den werten
paar fotos machen und eigentlich keine
war
vielleicht trotzdem wie kannst du aber
ganz ins wasser gehen übrigens aus dem
off the day eine wirklich wirklich
traumhaft neue hose liegt jetzt im trend
deshalb beschloss ist hier einfach mal
schwimmen ich war eigentlich ist jetzt
jedes jahr auch einmal hier am strand
schwimmen außer dieses jahr noch gar
nicht und irgendwie muss das eigentlich
auch mal machen mich alles um an weitere
kamera handhabt
eine richtig geile durch die mit 25
ich glaube ich jetzt einmal sachen also
seine sachen und verließ ich damals 14
aber mit einem ass
[Musik]
red
was
elisabeth merk dass ich deine sachen
genommen hat willst du deine schuhe
haben keiner gerne schuhe
[Musik]
hier könnte ein wenig als ich weiß wenn
ich noch lang
[Musik]
30 der sand ist sich auch eigentlich gar
nicht durch ein wischen
[Musik]
josef aber drei meter corner heraus
jetzt unglaublich viel gebracht weil ich
ja noch zwei stunden wegen sturms der
wand da sind ganz viele kinder die habe
ich alle angeguckt als recht uns was so
lustig fest war das was für ein schönes
draus irgendwann bin ich doch auch von
stein getreten was ist von fan idee oder
so kenne ich ja ganz nah doch nicht
schon
ich komme hier nochmals mittels dass wir
noch beenden oder er leitete er block
kommt dann am sonntag auch ich leider
das was ich heute stimmt hat mit dem was
morgen dann am nachmittag kommst du
zusammen also am sonntag gibt's dann
block wenn die resolution ist das war
doch noch unten also wenn ihr sagt
woanders verrichtet relativ last man
doch nach oben und wenn ihr sagt naja
dass man trotzdem eine runde
[Musik]